le plus grand concours de boules du Midi
c'est-à-dire du monde n'ayant pas peur
des mots nous sommes à Marseille c'est
déroulée au parc Aurélie et croyez mal à
l'endroit n'était pas trop fort pour
accueillir pas mal de joueurs
c'est la fête de la boule le concours du
provençale 1712 équipes engagées 5136
joueurs c'est à dire quelque chose comme
25000 personnes avec les supporters bien
décidés à ne pas perdre une bouchée
pendant une semaine il faut dire qu'il y
a comme des vedettes du vélo du football
des vedettes de la Seine il y a aussi
les vedettes de la boule et bien par
quand on tombe par hasard sur Henri
Salvador qui joint les deux qualités
c'est un spectacle qui vaut l'Olympia ou
même un bon shot télévisé voici donc
l'équipe d'Henri Salvador que les
hasards du tirage au sort ont placé face
au lion de la Valentine
il faut être à droite il faut être calme
il faut pas être gêné par le public et
ça je suis marrant
mais enfin vous avez vu ici c'est la
religion quand on joue une boule tout le
monde se taise Formule 1 beaucoup
d'entraînements
je suis sûr que
ça va
Marc Vial tireur de l'équipe Salvador
dans un échantillon de son travail
[Applaudissements]
mais je voudrais bien vous faire voir
mon petit croque-mort là parce que c'est
vraiment oui
c'est mon capitaine
vous jouez toujours tous les trois
maintenant
c'est le capitaine vous voyez la
casquette
qu'est-ce que vous faites comme boulot
et ben je mets dans les corbillard
quand même un moment où l'on se demande
à quoi rime cette passion cette passion
des boules
dans les boules c'est important l'amitié
c'est apporte le plaisir de gagner ça
apporte
comme on dirait la domination de
soi-même parce que dans les parties dure
il faut contrôler ses nerfs il faut on
arrive à se durcir et c'est tout le
plaisir de jouer la boule juste avec ce
petit morceau de d'acieron ça suffit ah
ouais parce que c'est même pas le
morceau de la cirrhose c'est le petit
bouchon en bois parce que c'est ce
bouchon qui fait
la joie ou le malheur des joueurs de
boules plus on y va après et plus il est
avec vous et plus on y va loin mais
malheureusement
elle va se faire effacer comme on dit à
Marseille
de vidéo
pour moi
c'est bon
mais vous faites n'importe quoi
vous comprenez maintenant pourquoi le
chant des bulles couvre parfois celui
des cigales en conséquence ne vous
étonnez pas de lire parfois dans les
journaux méridionaux des titres comme le
bombardier tout le nez à couler la
flotte marseillaise le bombardier tout
donner ses Baldi que voici un joueur de
légende celui-là on peut le dire mais
toujours à propos de titre je ne peux
pas résister à vous en citer un autre
relatant l'aventure d'un grand joueur il
s'appelait Jaurès qui avait un peu
injure embrassé Fanny Mascon assassine
Jaurès voilà comment on écrit l'histoire
ici on pourrait faire aussi un poème
avec les noms les surnoms des joueurs
bananes sardines Otello j'en passe pour
attirer votre attention sur trois des
meilleurs vainqueur cette année du
provençal Dédé ma Sony
gentricondie le japonais que voici et
Jean-Pierre perrondi qui joue ici contre
une sélection de l'Amicale Bouliste des
libérateurs
salut et Messieurs le point du vainqueur
[Musique]